I know you're in there who is this
gorgeous intruder you're harboring a
fugitive you're not taking him anywhere
I hereby challenge you for possession of
HR well you realize trial by combat to
the death
see you then you're gonna kill me as
king we just need a little practice
facing the wrong way again what am i
chances here scale one to ten she's
going to kill you it's a pretty solid
one
oh my god everybody we got full-blown
gypsy versus vibe battle in the episode
so let's break it down she's going to be
crazy but because the schedule is a
little different this week I'll have
some announcements at the end of the
video
it'll add links in the description for
everything new round of the flash ring
giveaway starts now all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video be sure to click
that bell to enable alerts so that you
don't miss any of my episode videos so
the big thing here is this is the gypsy
vs. vibe episode so it's very Cisco
centric but number 5 there's a very
special reason why they take her
character specifically for this episode
she debuted in Justice League of America
annual number two during 1984 but she
was also a huge character during vibes
comic book run during the new 52 which
you know big coincidence was written by
the showrunner of the flash Andrew
Kreisberg so she has really special
significance to the Cisco character in
the comics but also to the people who
write the flash which is really cool
Easter Egg right there during that
storyline she was an interdimensional
traveler a gypsy if you will see what
they did there fleeing from Cisco's
brother rupture who was being controlled
by this big evil person that I'll
explain in a second so Cisco steps in to
help her they go on the run together
they you know they formed this special
bond so you can see that's kind of
playing out in the course of the trailer
she's kind of an antagonist but they're
very playful about it Cisco wants to
take her on a date so number 4 what you
learn in the comics is that her father
is this evil metahuman warlord called
mortis who was exposed to the raw
energies of a boom tube from apocalypse
giving him a much more powerful version
of what Cisco's powers are so gypsies
real name is Cynthia mortis the actress
who's playing her is Jessica Camacho
some of you might recognize her from
Sleepy Hollow
but even though in the comics her father
is this crazy war Lord that has powers
given to him by something from
apocalypse I don't know if they're gonna
do him on the TV show so she might just
be a regular metahuman number 3 from
Earth 19 that's why she's coming
for HR they explained the premise of the
episode is the interdimensional travel
is outlawed on earth 19 HR broke that
law when he came to earth 1 so she's
trying to track him down to take him
back to prison so full-blown
versus by battle but she's way more
badass and way better with her power
since cisco is so it seems like barry
tries to stop her and she just shuts him
down instantly
so cisco has to step in in the comics
her powers are a little bit different
but she does have some vibes type powers
she has illusion casting camouflage she
can make people see crazy things to
freak them out she has a form of
precognition which is kind of like
Cisco's vibe ability like he can vibe
into the future she's an expert in
combat so even without her powers she's
a total badass so you get the sense here
that even though Cisco's training with
the gauntlets which it looks really
awesome you know number 2 cisco gets the
full vibe costume that he's gonna have
to find some other way to defeat her
like even though he's getting better
with his powers she's just so good in
the way she seems like she's a pretty
good person like she's not evil she'll
start working with him they'll find some
other way to resolve the conflict the
really cool thing you may have noticed
in the background are the king shark and
tarpit cutouts that he's using for
target practice now we've been talking a
lot about Gorilla Grodd but king shark
will eventually come back to remember
it's the multiverse so all these big
flash characters will reappear at some
point don't don't ever be surprised when
big characters come back anybody that's
like a fan favorite like the reverse
flash or even Eddy they'll always come
back in some way it's just a matter of
finding the right story finding out when
they can fit that in or when they can
fit it in their budget because sometimes
they'll blow their wad on big CG
episodes like this two-part gorilla City
episode that's coming so don't worry
king shark will come back soon but
number one because was a member of
the Justice League in the 80s she'll
probably end up working with team flash
eventually but because she's from earth
19 she probably won't stay forever but
she might come back for brief runs like
Jessie quick or Jay Garrick characters
that are free
other earth but they come help team
flash up for a couple episodes and they
go back to wherever they came from but
it seems like what they're implying is
is it Cisco which is going to be
obsessed with her in the way he was
obsessed with gold and glider but who
knows in a future season they might make
her a bigger character in speaking of
the future so the thing about the vibe
costume is that we actually saw it when
Cisco vibed Caitlin when she was worried
about killer frost stuff so we saw the
full-on killer frost versus vibe in
costume fight that might be from a
future where they don't change that
thing from the headlines they have that
board now with like all the things that
they're trying to change things like the
gorilla attacks still probably going to
happen so you just have to imagine the
Cisco was vibing a future from before
they started changing things so it's
still like darkest timeline when he's
seeing this fight you also notice the
dr. alchemy is working with the team
they let him on in the last episode so
now we're going to find out what he's
doing with them but the way Caitlin
tells it he's a metahuman expert so he's
going to help them deal with all the
other new people that pop up but I know
everybody's wondering if he's going to
betray the team if he has something to
do with savat are escaping the
speedforce again even though the
philosopher's stone was thrown into the
speedforce
there are a number of things that could
change for each of the characters they
explained that the flash prophecy will
sort of rotate depending on the events
that they change so the person that
betrays the team might have been
different in the original timeline
before they started changing things so
someone will die someone will suffer a
fate worse than death
someone will betray the team no matter
what happened but the people that those
things happen to will change so I'll do
a video about the flash prophecy in a
couple days because it's a pretty big
deal but let me know what do you guys
most hype about and I'll say
congratulations to the new flash ring
giveaway winner Andy please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details there
was a new round that started in this
video I'll just announce the winner when
I post my legends video in a couple more
hours so that will post before my arrow
video so it will be legends then my
arrow episode where you guys wait for
that to post click here for last night's
flash episode and you can click here to
learn about the Flash's new greatest
power in season 3 thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight